the reason that you should stop taking
advice from super successful people I've
noticed that there's a trend of people
who've made it explaining how work life
balance is actually what's most
important and how you can't be powered
by resentment or a sense of
insufficiency and it's a failure I think
on the part of the guru to understand
that the tools you need to get from n to
50 are not the same that you need to get
from 90 to 95 it's also a basic failure
of memory when you look at what got that
person to where they are it's precisely
the traits that they're now castigating
almost everybody has more pain and
resentment and fear in the beginning
which is why they all use it and once
you've achieved enough success and
validation from the world to not be
fueled by that anymore that's great that
doesn't mean that people who are just
starting out can achieve the success
that you now have by using strategies
which you only access after becoming
successful a much better way to do it if
you're looking at someone is not to
listen to what they're saying but to
look at what they did when they were at
the same stage as you